وعن السرديه وعن انتاجها اسال ضيفي من
الناصره ايهاب جبرين الكاتب المختص في
الشان الاصالي اهلا بك سيد ايهاب طبعا
تقرير الزميل الياس كرام طبعا احاط
بالموضوع موضوع الرقيب من مختلف الجوانب
ولكن ساخرج من صندوق هذا التقرير لاعود بك
الى ما جرى في جلسه محكمه العدل الدوليه
فيديوهات وثقها جنود اسرائيليون في غزه
اعتبرت من الملف وايضا ملف ادانه لما يقوم
به جيش الاحتلال ماذا عن افلات الافاعي من
كفي ومن يد الرقيب في هذه التجربه تجربه
الحرب في
غزه نعم تحيات استاذ عبد القادر ومساء
الخير يعني بدون ادن شك هذه كانت الجزئيه
ربما الاكثر ايلاما والاكثر حرجا
ل عمل الرقيب العسكري قبل اي شيء اخر في
نهايه المطاف كان هنالك ب يعني الجندي
الصغير ابن ال 18 او ابن 19 يعني الغير
مرئي في داخل المجتمع الاسرائيلي بهذا
المعنى يعني القصد بالصغير يحاول ان يسوق
نفسه بصوره الماتشو البطل بانه يقوم
باعمال بطوليه يعني لاحظ مثلا لل المفارقه
احد اهم الامور التي ادرجت مثلا في هذا
السياق انه في ذات اليوم الذي قتل به
الجيش الاسرائيلي جنوده واسرا في عمليه
مركبه انذاك فقط لانهم لوحوا ب
بال اللافته البيضاء وشعروا بالخطر فقط من
هذه التلويحه في ذات اليوم يقوم جندي
بتصوير مشهد
ل لفلسطينيين يحملون السلاح وكانهم
يستسلمون ويسيرون بالسلاح لاحظ المفارقه
الجندي الذي خاف من من الشريطه البيضاء
يعني يتباه بال بان هنالك فلسطين يستسلم
امامه وهو يمسك بالسلاح وعلى هذا الشريط
جزئيا تحديدا كان يتوجب على هاجار ان يقوم
بعمليه علاقات عامه بل نتنياهو كذلك قام
بعلاقات عامه وبعدها بويع اتى ذلك الشريط
الذي فضح كل الاشكاليه وكل جزئيه بمدى
الارباك في الميدان تحديدا وهنا تحديدا
هذه الجزئيه بان هنالك تمت فقدان سيطره
على ما يقوم به الجنود في داخل ارض
المعركه وارض الميدان وتحديدا بكل جزئيه
التوثيق يعني ين هنالك الكثير من الفضائ
على الذي وثقت الكثير من الشهادات التي
وثقت يعني بعيدا عن كل التحفيزات التي
كانت على المستوى السياسي المستوى العسكري
الميداني الجنود المتواجدون في داخل
الميدان يقومون بتوثيق انفسهم مع شهادات
ودلالات يعني يقولون احدهم الذي يعترف
باغتصاب اخر يعترف بمقتل كل هذه الامور
تسرب ليس عبر طريق الرقيب العسكري بل
مباشره الى التيك توك والى الانستغرام
والفيسبوك وكل اجهزه السوشيال ميديا التي
بطبيعه الحال لا يوجد لديه هنالك اي رقابه
ولا حتى
حتى حارج
هق حتى خارج مفهوم الاعلام البديل او
الاعلام الاخر ايضا واحد من اهم الملفات
واكثرها سريه في تاريخ اسرائيل ما يتعلق
بالبرنامج النووي الاسرائيلي في هذه الحرب
ايضا خرج مسؤول من اليمين المتطرف وقال
نضرب غزه بسلاح نوو
وبالتالي كيف كان اداء الرقيب او ماذا عن
مفهوم الرقيب في ضل هذا البعد
ايضا احد اهم اشكاليات اسرائيل في نهايه
المطاف ان المستوى السياسي بها بات متدنيا
كثيرا ولماذا هذا التدني في نهايه المطاف
لان هنالك خطاب شعوبي احد الامور التي
ساهمت في هذا الخطاب الشعبوي بدون ادنى شك
هي السوشيال ميديا يعني هنالك الكثير من
التصريحات التي كان فقط يحاولون عبرها كل
من يقومون بهذه الادلاء بعيدا عن مدى جديه
هذا التصريح من عدمه طبعا في نهايه المطاف
ومنطقه من عدمه في نهايه المطاف يعني
لنسال انفسنا من كان يدري ما هو اسم عمي
حاي الياهو او ما يسمى بوزير التراث في
داخل اسرائيل لولا لم يقم بمثل هذه
التصريح وهذه الجزئيه تحديدا يعني الكثير
من الوزراء والساسه الاسرائيليون واعضاء
الكنيست يقومون فقط بتسريحات بلهاء فقط من
اجل الشو والعرض الاعلامي ليس الا
واسرائيل في نهايه المطاف المؤسسه الكل
تدفع ثمنه ان كان في لهاي وان كان في
البروباجندا و الدور في امام الاعلام
الاجنبي وما الى ذلك وبطبيعه الحال من
يعني يقبع على عاتقه بقيام الدور الدفاعي
هذا هو دانييل هجار دونما غيره الناطق
بلسان ال الجيش وهنالك ربما جزئيه مهمه
جدا باللغه العبريه يسمونه كنايه عنه همرج
هلومي المهدئ الوطني هذه كانت دور يعني
الناطق بلسان الجيش او الرقيب العسكري
اجمالا هذا احد اهم الادوار التي توكل
اليه في في نهايه المطاف امام الشارع
الاسرائيلي عليه ان يغذي المعنويات من جهه
هذا في الجبهه الداخليه ان يغذي المعنويات
ان يصدر صوره النصر وان يتم هنالك تكتيم
اعلامي ان يحاول ان يقوم بالحصار الاعلامي
وربما فقط هناك على عجاله ولكن دوره امام
الاعلام الاجنبي هو ان يركز على دور
الضحيه واهميه دور اسرائيل في رد الفعل
والدفاع عن نفسه من النصره ايهاب جبارين
الكاتب المختص في الشان الاسرائيلي شكرا
جزيلا لك ne